so what a question for someone that
wanted to know why would you use MCT oil
in your coffee well let's talk about
that there is something called
bulletproof coffee where you're
combining one cup of coffee could be
between eight and twelve ounces with one
to two tablespoons of butter and one to
two tablespoons of MCT oil then you
would blend it up and drink it and
there's many benefits to doing this
especially when you start out doing keto
especially in a minute fasting because
it allows you to fast longer when we
talk about MCT oil we're talking about
medium chain triglycerides these are
special fats usually made from coconut
oil that turn into ketones pretty fast
so you're able to generate ketones as
fuel without really changing your diet
and a lot of times people add turmeric
or cinnamon or unflavored chocolate
powder or even sea salt to spike it
sometimes even chili powder as well
that'll actually give it a kick but
let's talk about the benefits of doing
this number one you're gonna have
physical energy why because ketones are
their preferred fuel of the brain in the
heart so you're gonna have more energy
right away and especially if you're
working out it's gonna help you get more
endurance all right next one is mental
clarity if there's any type of problem
with your focus or memory what that
means is that your neurons are starving
of glucose if you give it another fuel
source
ketones it will prefer that it will like
it and your memory and your clarity in
your focus will improve and then the
other thing is reduce appetite so if you
want to fast longer and not be hungry
MCT oil is one option there now also
ketones give you more oxygen less co2 so
compared to glucose it's just way better
and also I already mentioned this will
increase your time of fasting so it's
really important especially in the
beginning of your program to do this so
you can fast longer because fasting is
going to be so important in anything
that can speed that up is going to be
very beneficial
also it's going to help in the
transitional phase so when you're coming
off carbs and you're transitioning to
burning fat it's helpful to jumpstart
the system to get some ketones in your
body right away now there's a couple
points I want to mention about MCT oil
and I do have my own brand MCT oil and I
want to just give you some insights
about this pretty much all of the MCT
oil out there gets their product from
the same source and what you should know
is that we don't grow coconuts in the US
all MCT oil comes from non-us sources so
when someone says it's May than us well
it's just packaged in the US it's grown
in other countries my product is from
Indonesia but just realize that this
right here is kind of a marking gimmick
they don't manufacture the coconuts in
the US that is done overseas and then
they export it now the other thing about
MCT oil is I really think it's just way
way overpriced
this is a 16 ounce bottle if you compare
this with other brands out there they're
charging about twenty five thirty five
forty five dollars for a 16 ounce bottle
that is just way too expensive
what I charge for this is $12.95 and
it's pretty much the same product as you
see pretty much everywhere and if you
start at Quito or doing in a minute
fasting and you want to try this I put a
link down below check it out I think it
could help you